[Música]
y
el primer caso documentado de persona
que sea reinfectando por coronavirus es
el de un hombre de 33 años de hong kong
que ya dio positivo en una prueba pcr a
mediados de marzo tras presentar
síntomas leves de la enfermedad
kobe 19 sin embargo fue dado de alta a
mediados de abril pero ahora a finales
de agosto ha vuelto a dar positivo en
una prueba pcr tras viajar en españa' y
volver a hong kong vía el reino unido
sin embargo los investigadores de la
universidad de hong kong descartaron
rápidamente la hipótesis de que se
pudiera tratar de un portador
persistente del virus ya que detectaron
que la cepa que lo había infectado en un
primer lugar era distinta a la cepa que
lo infectó en un segundo lugar además en
esta infección en el paciente se
presentó a sintomático y los resultados
de este estudio fueron publicados en la
revista clinical infectious de 6
publicada por la universidad británica
de oxford es por eso que se habla del
primer caso documentado en el mundo
antes de que aparecieran otros casos
parecidos también aquí en europa y en
relación a los casos de la infección y
la organización mundial de la salud ha
declarado de que a pesar de que sean
y bajos en relación al total de
infectados en el mundo es importante
estudiarlos de cara a lo que nos puedan
decir en términos de inmunidad
[Música]
del caso del hong kong es re infectado
en bélgica también ha confirmado que una
ciudadana del país también se re infectó
del virus de kobe 19 se trata de una
mujer que se infectó dos veces en un
periodo de tres meses según las
autoridades científicas del país la cepa
de este virus había mutado genéticamente
11 veces algo que es bastante común
entre los coronavirus esta mujer en
cualquier caso está evolucionando muy
favorablemente apenas tiene síntomas
leves y tampoco necesitó hospitalización
el otro caso en europa se ha producido
en países bajos un hombre que se infectó
también de coronavirus de edad avanzada
y con patologías previas aseguran desde
países bajos
aún así los virólogos belgas aseguran
que el hecho de que haya casos de
infecciones no es una buena noticia
especialmente porque se han producido
infecciones en un periodo muy corto y se
esperaba que pueda ser algo más largo
aún así los biólogos aseguran que se
necesita más siempre
y ver si se trata sólo de casos aislados
[Música]
una persona de 46 años en quito que
había contraído el virus en el mes de
mayo de este año es el primer paciente
re infectado un ecuador luego de
resultar positivo en una prueba rápida
realizada en el mes de agosto el
instituto de microbiología de la
universidad de san francisco de quito
investigó el caso e informó que se trata
de una cepa distinta del virus sars
coptos donde el paciente manifestó
sentirse con mayor congestión flema
fiebre dolores de espalda y se sintió
más decaído el director del instituto de
microbiología de la casa de estudios
paul cárdenas informó que esto debe de
esperarse porque aseguran que existen
pacientes que no generan inmunidad
una vez superada la enfermedad la
diferencia de este paciente que en la
segunda ocasión han tenido mayores
síntomas un segundo caso de infección
también se detectó en la ciudad de
guayaquil un paciente de 39 años
vinculados al sector de la salud que en
este momento se mantiene en cuidados
intensivos ante dificultades
respiratorias pero los especialistas
aseguran que no debe de esperarse que
todos los contagiados vuelvan a
reinfectarse y exhortaron a no suavizar
la medida de protección
[Música]